So during that absolutely stunning interview
with Fox News's Chris Wallace, which we looked
at earlier, Chris Wallace mentions a Fox News
poll where Biden is ahead of Trump 49 to 41.
And the poll actually has a ton of fascinating
data points now as a reminder.
Fox News polling and Fox News Channel are
two different things.
Fox News polling is actually considered quite
good and and accurate.
So a few things as we get into it.
This is a poll of registered voters.
Remember that the least accurate in terms
of predicting an election is to just survey
all adults.
More accurate is registered voters and then
ideal is likely voters, although you tend
to see fewer likely voter polls this early.
You see more of those as we get closer to
Election Day.
Now, one other thing just to short circuit
those claims about, oh, they only called landlines.
We can't trust this, as you can see in the
methodology.
This was done with a 237 landline recipients
and eight hundred and sixty seven cell phones.
So they call cell phones.
This was mostly cell phones.
Now, on key issues, super important on the
economy, 47 to 47.
Biden and Trump on.
Who is better to handle the economy?
The economy has been Trump's one issue lately
where he was polling better than Joe Biden
last week in the Quinnipiac poll.
Joe Biden pulled better than Trump on the
economy in this Fox News poll.
They are tied.
That's not good for Trump.
Not surprisingly, on race relations, Trump
is way underwater.
Only 35 approve.
Thirty five percent approve of Trump.
On race relations, 56 percent disapprove.
I already mentioned Biden up 49 to 41 by eight
in the general election poll right now.
Four percent say they would vote for other.
Five percent say they don't know yet.
And then now it gets really interesting when
vote when a poll recip a poll, a poll.
What would we call them?
Poll takers.
Subjects were asked about vote by mail.
Sixty three percent of the country says they
favor vote by mail, compared to 28 percent
who oppose.
This suggests that Trump, loudly opposing
vote by mail, as he has been doing, may not
really be a good strategy to bring more people
over to his side.
Now, this is really important and very interesting.
I recently said if they have debates, Biden
shouldn't go at Trump's insults or wacky behavior.
I said there are three primary issues that
have hurt Trump and that should be the focus
corona virus, the economy as a result of corona
virus and the protests.
Jorge Floyd, race issues.
When asked what are the most important issues
today, the issues are.
Twenty nine percent say coronavirus.
Fifteen percent say the economy, jobs and
unemployment.
And 10 percent say race relations and police
issues.
So those three issues are the top issues for
54 percent of the country.
It's really important to confirm our hypotheses.
It appeared that Corona virus, the economy
and race relations were the most important
issues and the ones that had hurt Trump the
most.
And indeed, it appears that that is the case.
Now, last thing, there was a question about
mental soundness.
For years we've been seeing concerning signs
from Trump about his cognitive state.
There's also a Joe Biden has dementia movement.
I've admitted Biden has definitely slowed
down from where he was in his 60s, despite
it not appearing to be dementia.
According to every mental health expert I've
spoken to, the poll asked.
Do you think Biden and Trump have the mental
soundness to serve effectively as president?
Forty seven percent believe Biden has the
mental soundness.
Only 43 percent believe Trump does.
Now, those numbers are just really low.
The fact that neither candidate has half the
country believing they are mentally sound
is a problem.
But note that 14 percent aren't sure about
Biden.
Seven percent aren't sure about Trump.
The important takeaway is more people question
Trump's fitness for office than Biden's, although
not by a huge margin.
So the big takeaways here are our instincts
about what matters.
This election has been right.
The polls are consistently showing similar
results and we all have to assume nothing
and vote like our state depends on our vote
to choose between Trump and Biden.
That's how we should imagine we are going
to act on a on November 3rd or before if you're
voting early.
And I hope many of you do.
My vote could swing my state from Trump to
Biden.
I'm sure as hell voting in that case.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David Pakman.
We'll be right back.